The slopes we end up with are 10 for brand 1, 8 for brand 2, and 10, again, for
brand 3. This is really interesting. For both brand 1 and brand 3, when we move
over 10 in the x-direction, we have to move up 100 in the y-direction. And, of
course, 100 divided by 10 is just 10. I drew this right triangle on the gray
line, which corresponds to brand 1, but this same exact triangle can be drawn
for the line for brand 3. This has exactly the same proportions. It doesn't
however work for brand 2. What's even more interesting, however, is how this
ties in with our equations. We said before that brand 1 and brand 3 seem the
most similar because they both had coefficients of 10 in their x terms. 10 is
what we found for the slope of each of them as well. So, seems like this number,
the coefficient of the x term in our equation corresponds to the slope of the
line. This is also true for brand number 2, we see a coefficient of 8 in the
term 8x, and a slope of 8.